ukraine says it's regained territory
across several regions including kharkiv
a significant setback for russia so is
this a turning point in the conflict and
how will moscow respond this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo after nearly seven months of
fighting ukraine has finally begun to
regain some of the territory it lost to
russia it says its forces are continuing
their rapid advance in several areas
including the northern kharkiv region in
the past few days forcing moscow to pull
back its forces it's raised the question
of how far they can go now in response
to those gains ukraine says russia is
attacking its power and water supplies
in kharkiv officials say missile strikes
caused blackouts in several areas
including the main city power was
restored in denipro petrovsk doniersk
and sumi by midnight on sunday but
kharkiv remained in darkness an
estimated 9 million people were affected
including in areas controlled by russia
despite the days of battlefield setbacks
the kremlin's top spokesman insists the
war is on track saying the special
military operation is underway and will
continue until the goals that have been
set are achieved
al jazeera's hold abdulhamid has more
now from kharkiv
since the beginning of september the
ukrainian army has been
carrying out this counter-offensive in
the northeast of the country taking by
surprise everyone especially when it
comes to the speed at which it has been
able to recapture territory occupied by
the russian army some 3 000 square
kilometers according to the chief of
staff here now the russians on their
side are saying that they're actually
pulling out and regrouping to
concentrate on the donbass region
further east in
ukraine
but it seems that the ukraine had
managed to trick the russians in the
sense that they were talking about a
counter-offensive in the south of the
country in the herzone region and
some are saying that the russians had
actually pulled out some of their troops
from this side of the country to beef
out
their presence in the gerson region
nevertheless at this point the
ukrainians
have managed to reach some strategic
towns like kopiansk and issue if they
manage to fully control those towns well
there it's a big blow for the russians
who use those places as logistical hubs
and back up for the troops that are
based in the donbass region the question
now is will they be able to hold all
this territory and what is russia's next
step already russia has shown that it
will continue hitting cities a critical
infrastructure was struck plunging
kharkiv and other regions here in the
east in darkness just yesterday uh
people here wondering what would be the
next move honda abdulhamid for inside
story
well russia has acknowledged its losses
in ukraine's northern kharkiv region a
russian installed official there says
ukrainian forces outnumbered russian
troops in the counter-offensive retaking
sways of land since early september
ukrainian troops have advanced rapidly
areas that took russia months to seize
have been retaken in just days ukrainian
flags are now flying in the cities of
issum and kopiansk both on railway lines
that serve as a supply route for russian
troops ukraine says it has also made
gains in the south near kirsan but at a
slower pace
well let's bring in our guests now in
live michaelo vanesky political
commentator and professor at the
national university of kiev mojilla
academy in moscow victor olivich is a
lead expert at the center for actual
politics and in oxford samuel romani
associate fellow at the royal united
services institute gentlemen welcome to
you all thank you very much for joining
us on inside story uh mikhailo in live
let me start with you if i can
remarkable advances by the ukrainians
how have they been able to make these
breakthroughs so quickly well in fact
we've been i mean at the end of the day
we've been preparing for this for a very
long time uh as you mentioned in the
first segment of the program uh we were
expecting an a counter advance or a
counter attack uh in the south uh
clearly that has uh probably diverted
some of the russian forces away from
defense uh around the uh the
northeastern part it is important to
note that the people that are actually
on the ground liberating uh the areas of
kharki oblast are actually not regular
army soldiers these are people from the
territorial brigades in other words
these are people that volunteered after
the february 24th uh they've received
significant amounts of training in the
last six months and they're very very
motivated to uh to uh liberate to
liberate the occupied lands of their
country and i think i also want to say
that the fact that it has been going
very very quickly has actually been a
surprise not only to uh those of us that
are observing it it's actually been a
surprise to the ukrainian central
command they were expecting this
offensive to last until the end of
september
uh well as we see uh it's gone a lot
quicker than expected a lot of really
motivated people what's happening what's
great in their favor you think well
there's there's two things first of all
uh they've got a lot of support from the
local
local population i mean the local
population in kharkivo is absolutely no
desire to be occupied by the russians uh
and they are obviously greeting uh the
ukrainian forces as liberators secondly
um the ukrainians have a strategy of
attack and that is our strategy of
military action and that has been proven
very effective it's a strategy of
decentralization it's a strategy of if
you like network kind of of
of of actions um central commanders give
sort of general directions and then uh
the people on the ground themselves are
making the decisions and i imagine
motivated
i imagine the military support provided
by the west has also helped but we'll
come back to that in just a moment let
me bring in victor
in moscow victor russia's admission of a
withdrawal in israel is significant
because this was of course a major
military hub for moscow
the russians say they are regrouping but
i wonder how is this being viewed in
moscow what is the reaction there and
how is the kremlin explaining these
setbacks well this is not the first
setback uh in russia's military
operation in ukraine in the last six
months several months ago russian forces
retreated from the kia from the areas of
kiev and chinega regions that
they controlled uh later on
the izmini uh island uh had been
had been lost by the russian forces and
now we are witnessing a retreat
from the uh kharkov region from those
areas of the kharkov region that russian
forces controlled this is being openly
discussed uh on
various panels and
this is being openly discussed on
russian television
in russian media there are different
reactions but what is important uh to
state is that russia
is not going to be defeated on the
battlefield russia is a great power and
it cannot afford a military defeat but
how is how is the russian defense
ministry explaining these retreats how
is it justifying these retreats
well the russian defense ministry is
being tight-lipped it is
saying that a retreat has happened to
prevent a large
loss of personnel
and that is about it
but it is being discussed on various
levels and it is again it is important
to note that this is not
uh the end of russia's efforts in
ukraine and russia will
continue with its special military
operation in ukraine uh until it either
reaches its uh goals that were set in
the beginning which seems to be very
difficult at this point to to to focus
or if a
solution if a diplomatic solution okay
is found between a solution that will
involve both russia the west and ukraine
and the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov uh just yesterday said that
russia is still looking for a diplomatic
uh solution to this crisis we'll talk
about the diplomatic
solution and and whether talks can still
happen at this stage samuel romani let
me bring bring you into the conversation
as victor said there it's not the first
time that we're seeing a retreat from
russian forces how significant are these
recent gains by the ukrainians in the
wider conflict is it even more
significant do you think than the
russian retreat from from kiev back in
march well the russian retreat from kiev
back in march was a major recalibration
of the mission it marked the end of
phase one of what they call the special
military operation and the start of
phase two so it implicitly meant that
for the foreseeable future regime
changing here the overthrow zelensky and
his replacement by a pro-russian figure
like patriarch or victor medvedchuk or
someone of that elk who had more
grassroots support was not possible so
both of them are very significant but
significant for different reasons when
it comes to the
recent events in karaki the russians
military establishment appears to be
been blindsided because you see from
russian telegram russian military
experts were warning that what ukraine
was doing in kurzan was
only uh the first phase of the operation
was a bit of a faint the real focus
would be on a blitz for car cave and it
appeared as if the russian defense
ministry was caught off guard and now
they've lost their supply lines so it's
quite complicated also for their
campaign in donetsk because cooperation
and israel are very important for the
offensive operations that they're
carrying out in places like bhakti and
solidar and it's also coincided with
ukraine breaching into lehman
potentially and meaning that russia and
donetsk will be fighting an offensive
operation and now defensive operation at
the same time strategically samuel what
are the russians missing right now well
strategically one of the things i think
that they're having a bit of difficulty
with is now supply lines and they're
going to have to reject and figure this
out because we've seen mi26 helicopters
which can carry between 935 personnel
being carried over to bring supposed
reinforcements into car key but the
problem is those helicopters are very
vulnerable to man pads and other uh
defensive equipment that the ukrainians
have managed to get from nato countries
so they're having a bit of difficulty
now in terms of making sure they don't
have a repeat of what's happening in
kurzan where you have 20 000 troops
stuck there and all the bridges are
destroyed and they're trying to build a
pontoon ferry and the ukrainians stack
that too and that's their initial
problem i think right now and also they
need to be careful but where the
ukrainian counterfeits is going to
happen next some people think it might
go through bavolidar and into don yet
there's apparently a movement into
luhansk allegedly if you believe the
ukraine's governor sergey haidai in
delicious chansk and then there's a
campaign in kurzan ukraine may come for
multiple axes or might unexpectedly
concentrate on one and leave russia
blindsided again so guessing ukraine's
next move is very difficult for the
russians okay well let's take a look at
the sort of support ukraine has been
getting from the west ukraine's recent
gains have been largely due to the huge
amount of western military aid it's
received in the past few months let's
take a closer look at the numbers in
total more than 30 countries have
provided military equipment the us has
contributed the most by far with at
least 12.5 billion dollars in military
aid poland follows behind supplying
weapons worth 1.83 billion dollars and
the uk has pledged the third largest
amount with weapons worth
1.36 billion dollars but ukraine's
president has appealed for more funding
saying the monthly cost of defense was
about five billion dollars mi kylo
vanesky i saw you shaking your head
there you don't seem to agree with me
that that western
military support is indeed what is
helping ukraine right now uh regain the
territory it's lost
no i i i i
i agree with you that master military
support is absolutely key uh and that we
are we're receiving and we're very
grateful for the fact that we're
receiving a very large amount of
ammunition of
of equipment etc and this is one of the
reasons that i i vehemently disagree
with victor who says that uh the russian
army cannot be defeated on the
battlefield it can be defeated and we
will see its defeat in the next little
while the important thing to understand
is that this particular gain in kharkiv
in fact was not really supported by
western military equipment um the
western military equipment that has come
into the country was concentrated
largely in the south in the hassan
region and it has been used for for
example the haimar systems in other
words the multiple rockets uh very very
accurate multiple rocket systems have
been used uh for uh attacking supply
lines in the south uh in the eastern
part of the country in the northeast
specifically we've been seeing actually
a a battle basically with old soviet era
equipment because these have been uh as
i mentioned before the territorial
brigades that are actually doing the
fighting uh yes they have some man pads
yes they have some uh some uh some of
the mobile equipment um uh javelins and
that sort of thing that were supplied at
the beginning of the war uh but this is
not really recent stuff
what is i think really uh phenomenal is
that if we look at the amount of
captured russian equipment in the last
two weeks uh those numbers the number of
of anti-tank or excuse me of
anti-personnel or personnel carriers uh
tank weapons uh and ammunition actually
outnumbers the amount of aid that we've
been getting from the west so in fact
the largest supplier of military
equipment to the ukrainian armed forces
at the moment is russia victor your
response
well russia cannot afford a defeat in
ukraine because a defeat in ukraine
would mean a very serious political
consequences in russia itself and uh of
course russia is going to do
everything it can and the russian armed
forces are going to uh do uh their
outmost to prevent
a defeat
how do they do that how does russia do
that
it seems to be short on weapons short in
ammunition and also short of soldiers
how are they going to achieve this
objective
the objectives of this special operation
as they're calling it
the initial objectives of the special
military operation that were outlined by
the russian president in february are at
this point difficult to achieve
the objectives now are
somewhat more
limited
and where but we see the same you see we
see a very bellicose rhetoric from both
sides a rhetoric which cannot be
realized on the front
when we discuss russian objectives from
february 24th
and the uh how unlikely it is that they
will be uh achieved in the near future
we have to also look at the objectives
that ukrainian officials are putting
before their forces today and how
unrealistic those objectives are we see
ukrainian officials who say that their
objective is to uh take uh crimea or to
take uh the donetsk and lugansk regions
is there is something very different
about crimea and the donetsk and lugansk
regions from from the hierarchy
of disagreements just disagrees with the
ukrainian forces
different
let me explain for a second
what's different is
ethnically russian
it's not about taking crimea or taking
the next it's about liberating those
areas that have been occupied by russia
since 2014
and this has nothing to do with
ethnicity or language uh and i do want
to say that one of the original
objectives of the special military
operation in fact invasion was
demilitarization well my dear russian
friends you're doing a wonderful job of
it you're demilitarizing yourself on
ukrainian soil and in fact supplying the
ukrainians with your wonderful weapons
and at this point running away from the
battlefield the objective of liberating
occupied territories on the ukrainian
side has not changed since 2014 it's
something that we have been ongoing and
and going after in a very crimea is
ukrainian
okay samuel before i bring you back into
the conversation i'll just allow victor
to respond to to what mikhailov has just
said there the objective and also
mikhail i want to hear from you whether
people still think this is this is a
special operation in russia because this
is now an all-out war from from the
looks of it
the official ukrainian statements on the
need or the wish to take back crimea are
militarily unrealistic
this is not going to happen what's
happening is that both sides are setting
up unrealistic objectives and
it seems that
the one of the ways that is still open
to resolve this conflict is a diplomatic
solution but that solution the
diplomatic solution
is only going to be able to be achieved
if the west
uh
seeks gives it a green light it was the
ukrainian side and it was the west that
brought
an end to the negotiation negotiations
process okay that was launched in
belarus in uh in the early march and
then continued in istanbul in turkey
the ukrainian side that left those
negotiations okay accusations and
counter accusations of course when it
comes to who left the negotiations and
who doesn't want to talk samuel i want
to bring you into the conversation on
that point of negotiations do you think
now is a good time to resume talks and
negotiations to end the conflict or is
ukraine now in a position
that it feels that it no longer needs to
negotiate well i think that there's been
an extra bit of radicalization on both
sides so if you look at some of the
rhetoric even in russia after the defeat
in car cave you see people like dimitri
medvedev from the security council
talking about how our ultimate goal is
the total capitulation of ukraine and
the ultimatums that zelensky calls them
that we offer them are just like
children's play and on the other hand
you see the ukrainians saying that
there's no use in dialogue with russia
until because we need to focus on
liberating all of our territory
including crimea
and that given the fact that there's a
extreme another extreme rhetoric on both
sides against negotiations uh i think
it's going to be very unlikely to see
diplomacy and dialogue come forward the
russian terms in particular seem to be
quite unrealistic if you listen to elena
zlitsky from the state duma they're
talking about the complete densification
of ukraine which would imply effectively
zelinski advocating and some kind of a
regime change or some kind of a
extinction extinguishing of ukrainian
culture to some degree so there's a bit
of a a real sense of maximalism coming
from russia i think that it's unlikely
that we'll see peace talks being held
turkey has expressed some optimism that
we could have talks based on the black
sea grain deal to apply to other
theaters like this operation nuclear
plant and then maybe towards a broader
settlement right but they seem to be
standing alone in that one so
and i also think the ukrainians now have
a sense of confidence that they can
really win this militarily even if it
takes months or even
longer than that and i think that it's
going to be ultimately going to be
fought on the battlefield not the
bargaining table and how safe samuel do
you think putin in is in all of this
there seems to be
cracks now in the narrative well there
are cracks in the narrative but the
cracks in the narrative are not coming
from liberals right it's not the alexei
navalny's it's not people having
anti-war demonstrations the cracks are
coming from the hardliners who wanted to
really keep russia exactly we want to
see russia all the way to kiev russia
will win this war with the maximal
objectives that were stated by putin in
february 24th and also many people who
are calling now for a total mobilization
so it's like the former donbass
commander eager
of gurkhan and ramzan khadirov who want
a reevaluation of the russian ministry
of defense's strategy and a lot of the
blame is being placed on sergey shoigu
who is a civilian he's an emergency
minister he wasn't actually a military
personnel and not necessarily on the
head of vladimir putin at this time
right so putin seems to be
shielded from some of the criticism it's
going more to the defense minister all
right victor in moscow uh there is
indeed talk of total mobilization from
the hawks in russia are we going to see
a conscription now of russian soldiers
and are russians ready to fight for
russia the russian government at this
point is not looking to
to impose total or mass mobilization in
russia this would have
significant consequences for the russian
economy uh it would uh
take a number of uh able-bodied men uh
from other positions at various russian
economic industrial organizations and
put them on the front
russia is also
would also have to provide
all of those new conscripts with weapons
systems uh and uh other military
equipment at this point this may simply
not be available so russia so how are
they going to win this when the special
military operation well at this point at
this point it is important for russia
not to be defeated
and russia is going to do its utmost not
to suffer a defeat in ukraine you see a
lack of a defeat in ukraine does not
mean the is not the same as achieving
all the goals that were set
out on february 24th
so both sides are essentially both the
russian side and the ukrainian side are
the goals that are were initially set or
are now being set by the ukrainian side
are unrealistic it is uh again i will
repeat
it is uh hard to imagine that russia in
the near future will be able to uh get a
regime change in kiev and at the same
time it is
highly unlikely that the ukrainian side
will be able to achieve all the military
goals it is setting out
next to
the chances of
regaining crimea for ukraine are next to
nil okay mikhail i'm going to give you
the last word in uh lev what else is
likely to shape the situation on the
ground and elsewhere well i'm very i'm
very pleased that uh that
according to our colleagues in moscow
the the the goal now of the russians is
not to win the war it's to not be
defeated uh well i want to uh
that that was actually a very very
a poignant point made by victor well in
this case the ukrainian side is looking
for victory and victory for us is very
simple it's regaining the territories
that have been occupied illegally by
russia that includes all of the
territories that were demarcated and
have been internationally recognized uh
since 1991 uh it includes crimea whether
this is resolved 100 militarily we will
see this is not a war that is going to
end soon unfortunately okay uh this is
probably going to last for for a while a
while longer but i have no doubt about
the fact that the turning point has in
fact been reached
gentlemen thank you very much for a
great discussion mikhail vanesky victor
oliveich and samuel romani
and thank you two for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can of
course also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me fully [ __ ] and the whole
team here in doha thanks for watching
bye for now
[Music]
[Music]